okay so in case some of you out there
don't know dispite trackable super
having ended over two years ago toy
animation has been on a semi-regular
basis producing a new Dragon Ball series
and trust me I'm using the word series
loosely in reality there are currently
22 9 minute long episodes released
promote a digital card game based in
Japan I love Japan period now as some of
you older fans of the channel might
remember I've actually talked about
super Dragon Ball heroes before however
when I spoke about the show first it had
only just started and I covered only
four episodes as of course that was all
that was released at the time and it
didn't go well
now there are over 20 episodes released
with fully finished arcs to boot and
trust me they are just as weird if not
more so than before which let's be
honest sounds exactly like the sort of
challenge I enjoy Dragon Ball GT s first
season really tested my patience but
something tells me this will be much
much worse I'm totally not Marc and this
is my review for the first 20 episodes
of super Dragon Ball heroes V anime Oh
also make sure to stick around for the
end because I have a big announcement to
make
alright let's dive in
frizam planet ark episodes 1 2 4 recap
all right so because I've technically
taken a look at the first four episodes
before I'll try to cover these quickly
to get everyone caught up if you are
already caught up you can use this time
stamp to jump to when I discuss episode
5 and onwards in my last video about
this I discussed the shortcomings of
super Dragon Ball heroes in an overly
light-hearted fashion but as I said in
that review the show plays extremely
fast and loose with the concept of whoa
my logic and maybe even story telling
the entire story essentially acts as an
excuse to get Goku Vegeta and trunks
into a circumstance where they are
forced to battle random and I mean
random enemies while demonstrating more
crazy power-ups and fusions future my
arrives during Goku and Vegeta's
training embarrasses world whoa and no
one asks any questions as to why that
happens but she informs the gang that
apparently trunks is being held captive
on a prison planet which is pictured as
a bunch of planets literally chained
together complete with Saturn and planet
Earth
alright so essentially this purple guy
with a hipster haircut is the bad guy
that's responsible for the prison planet
and once there Goku and Vegeta run into
tight patrol Goku from another time
lenin they fight for all of three
seconds before joining forces
apparently they need to gather 7 Dragon
Balls don't ask and the remaining six
are in the hands of other prisoners on
the planet the first big bad that shows
up is cooler followed quickly after by
cumber and Yusei in use for the show and
the majority of the fight that takes
place in this arc is against him he's
quite strong leading to Goku Vegeta
fusing together using the pitar earrings
my has for some reason don't ask the
subsequent episode after that covers the
fight of vegeta vs cumber we also get to
see Vegeta using the kaio-ken in tandem
with the super saiyan blue form which is
kind of neat however combo resorts to
launching a blood slave ball into the
sky like Vegeta did way back when and
proceeds to change into a golden Azzaro
because of course he does Goku and
Vegeta then defused reveals that she has
more earrings because of course she does
Goku then gets trapped under cumbers
foot but goes blue and kaio-ken
to get out of there the fight that's
raging on against cumber is apparently
causing damage to the planets chains
which is important to foo the purple
hipster bag I spoke about before leading
to him having to take control of the
situation heeding cumber in some weird
way forcing him to her
back to his regular size but not cutting
his tail off in a feu then leaves again
Goku go Super Saiyan God and combo
recognizes the form for some reason and
you're pretty much caught up with
episode 5 if it doesn't make any sense
that's because it actually doesn't make
any sense all right
episode 5 goku fights combure in his god
form when she can't anymore seems he's
active energy and combo crushes him to
the floor now lying motionless cumber
lines up his final blast and Goku there
and then when out of nowhere like
everything else in the series Super
Saiyan 4 time patrol Goku Vegeta show up
to make the save they then begin
throwing on the ear bling themselves
resulting in Super Saiyan 4 time patrol
vegeto which might actually be the
dirtiest thing I've ever said in my life
now fuse they resume fighting cumber in
Goku's place breaking more and more
chains of a planet in the process
leading to what looks like the collapse
of the planet entirely the fire is a
coming-home a hollow launch encumber
into the sky seemingly defeating him
however all the energy that they've
released results in them defusing and
food that arrived on the battlefield
enraged with the condition his planet
and his lab have been left in apparently
it's time for him to take things into
his own hands now episode 6 episode 6 is
sort of the finale of this arc so let's
see how this one plays out alright so
the episode kicks off with the planet
going to all hell as the time patrol
forces of Goku and Vegeta in their super
saiyan 4 forms battle at formidable Fuu
suddenly cumber floats back down from
the sky he was blasted into ready to
join the battle once again all the while
our main Goku lying motionless on the
floor is still lying motionless on the
floor however Fuu notices something in
the sky remarking that it looks like he
has achieved his goal after all that
quote they will revive soon he then
thanks the stay ends before piecing out
through a portal he cuts open escaping
from the action entirely cumber
meanwhile is throwing a massive blast
towards the remaining fighters the Super
Saiyan fours are just about able to hold
off this blast but they are struggling
our Vegeta meanwhile starts shouting at
our Goku to wake up and I did typical
Goku fashioned oh so at last
possible second and in his ultra
instinct state no less
Goku precedes the school cumber until he
has been left unconscious and it's at
this point once again drained of energy
after the short ultra instinct scuffle
the masu flanked by a number of other
characters begin exiting that thing in
the sky Fuu were marked on earlier they
take cumbers lifeless body away and
leave Goku on the planet to meet his
doom Goku screams and the planet goes
boom ending the episode and the arc and
now we're diving into super Dragon Ball
Heroes second ever arc the universe
conflict and while I poked fun at the
previous arc for very obvious reasons it
was still able to do something the
Dragon Ball super anime couldn't connect
two acts together rather than just
starting a fresh story this is a
legitimate point towards heroes that
super doesn't have and I can't believe I
just said that episode seven after
regrouping embarrasses world the time
patrol Vegeta and Goku leave hoping that
the Goku we know is okay it's at this
point the plot comes running down the
road in the form of the Supreme Kai from
the sixth universe why doesn't he just
teleport like the rest of the Kai's do
who knows
appearing terrified he informs them that
the sixth Universe is being attacked by
unknown enemies I don't know why he runs
all the way to the seventh universe to
bring this to the attention of these
random mortals he met once and not to oh
I don't know any other god of
destruction
apparently Shanta the god of destruction
of his universe is after being called
somewhere else which is convenient or
part of the plot who knows you decide
Vegeta then accepts the Judy and vows to
defend to the 6th universe we then
switch scenes catching up with hit Kaba
cauliflower and kale in universe 6 as
they are fighting the portal hoppers
from the end of the last arc together
they are struggling but are inflicting
some damage here and there however these
two creepy twins are capable of healing
their wounds thankfully Vegeta and
trumps joined the fray and together help
level the playing field however these
two have one more thing up their sleeves
and they won't reveal it until the next
episode alright episode 8 the episode
itself kicks off as the two enemies
demonstrate this technique both of their
designs look very reminiscent of baby
from GT and their ability seems to be
very similar to they can possess and
inhabit the bodies of kale and
cauliflower in their hair white and
putting strange marks on their face I'm
not really sure as to why they take
their bodies as their own though they
later reveal that they are tough will
engineer
parasites and if they do work like baby
then why would they willingly make
themselves weaker by using cauliflower
and kale as hosts
they already visually told us that they
were much weaker than those two twins
were in the first place so it redoes n't
make sense for them to inhabit their
bodies also just as an aside Kaaba has
literally done nothing in these past two
episodes so far and I think it's
hilarious Vegeta even paraded him once
anyways hidden trunks end up fighting
the to parasites wild Vegeta charges his
final flash the build-up to this final
flash is actually more visually
interesting than that from the universe
sixth term in the super I think so
that's something but the finish is one
of the dumbest things I've ever seen his
and trunks his plan was to hold the two
parasite twins in full Nelsons like Goku
did with Raddatz and just take the hit
from Vegeta
I guess this isn't a big deal as no one
is mortally wounded or even hurt as much
as you think they should be after the
attack and on top of that the two
parasites exited the bodies before the
blast hit so neither of them are hard
done by either oh and also this other
guy riding a giant crystal wearing a
mink coat and weird sunglasses shows up
and forces everyone to the floor he
reveals that he is there to take down
Zeno and his name is Hart's but no joke
the ending to this is sort of dramatic
parts demonstrates that he could destroy
all of them in an instant if he so
chooses
he reads hits mind to find out that
Geron is the strongest in all the
universe's we see Vegeta confused as to
where Goku is right now and we get a
quick glimpse at jiren staring down
cumber with topo defeated on the floor
and to make matters even more confusing
we switch sees the grand priest
addressing Goku dressed as the grand
priest I don't know what's going on but
I'm kind of getting into it
episode 9 the episode begins in a weird
way trunks and Vegeta suddenly appear in
universe 11 no idea how they got there
either or how the other episode sort of
resolved itself I guess they just took
the bus or something so without delay
Vegeta gets taken over by one of the
parasites and pretty much turns into
baby this is such a weird show time and
time again I am reminded that this isn't
trying to tell a good story but instead
trying to cram as many things into it as
possible to sell toys games and cards
you know trunks gets knocked into the
ocean and that's when we catch up with
Doran's battle with
cumber in the middle of this fight
hearts interrupts and instructs the new
parasite vegeta to battle him in cumbers
place parts then teleports cumber to
universe 3 as the battle rages on in
universe 11 the girl parasite and
Tsubasa show up trunks does too to be
flung to the side seconds who didn't see
that coming and that's when Grand Prix's
Goku arrives the battlefield like Thor
from infinity war flanked by the actual
crime priest who deems it not necessary
to stick around because it seems Goku is
tapping into ultra instinct again to
which I say no grand priest please stick
around that move doesn't last long and
you should know that anyway
Goku pretty much got punches the
parasite out of Vegeta in Woodhead
because that that makes sense bringing
the episode to a close as he stares down
hearts one thing I've actually noticed
about these episodes is that the music
is new and honestly quite good which I
literally did not expect episode 10 goku
moves to confront hearts but gets
blindsided by the parasite twins
Geron is fighting Zama so in the
meantime but the twin fight is just so
bizarre in the same fashion as every
episode before it yet another character
fusion slash form is revealed apparently
these parasite twins confuse and fuse
they so do the fusion is called kami
orange yeah a fusion of the names cumin
and orange the two parasites they
however can still not touch Goku this is
what hearts calls this other character
from this giant flying crystal she
emerges and starts slicing Goku up with
her jagged pieces no longer an ultra
instinct he doesn't stand a chance
I guess the grand priest should have
stuck around in the first place the
episode ends as vegeta goes Super Saiyan
blue ER to try and even the odds against
cameo episode 11 episode 11 begins as
Vegeta battles cameo in a dominant
fashion wild trunks defends Goku from
crystal girl we cut to Jaron who seems
to be dealing with some ah soo rather
well look that it matters because he's
immortal and journeys justa
out of seemingly nowhere the animation
quality in this episode skyrockets as
none Tashia provides a cut of animation
for Vegeta's final flash against kami or
the attack was successful and it
separates the two parasites Goku all the
while continues to get sliced by
crystals when yet again Heights cuts in
and sends crystal girl to reinforce
cumber in universe three parts then
initiates a fight with Goku in the hopes
that it will draw out the perfect ultra
instinct form he had earlier so that he
can defeat him at his strongest the bold
strategy cotton let's see if it pays off
for once again hearts forces everyone to
the floor and this is when another
person enters the fray Supreme Kai shows
up so that he can teleport everyone away
despite Goku already having that ability
I don't know jeering gets trapped in
little box and we get more food sitting
in a lab watching everything unfold
before we get a glimpse of mecha cooler
to close out the episode this is such a
fever dream of a series episode 12
episode 12 begins as hearts and his
giant crystal arrive in the seventh
universe and that's when we see Goku
Vegeta trunks 17 and piccolo standing in
defense of the earth character episode
introductions like this makes me feel
serious whiplash considering we were
just in universe 11 but whatever I guess
they all just took the bus again
but I digress they start to fight Vegeta
and trunks take on fuse ama sue 17 and
piccolo take on the parasite twins and
Goku struggles against Hearts we then
switch gears to universe 3 where we see
metal cooler fighting cumber and then
transform into golden metal cooler
because they gotta sell stuff in firing
his final big blast cooler ruptures a
circuit overheating and then flies away
almost immediately we then switch back
to the main action in universe 7 to find
that the parasite twins are fused again
and hearts looks as though he's ready to
finally start fighting episode 13 for
the record I don't really enjoy the
designs of hearts or anyone in the show
for that matter it feels very much like
a random fan came up with the concepts
and designs and Towey instructed
professional artists to draw them
regardless Goku at hearts commenced
fighting I have no idea why he just
doesn't use the gravity thing he does
more but whatever Goku powers up to
Super Saiyan blue time to take things
seriously now I guess even though it was
already pretty serious
before I do like the idea however that
heart stays one step ahead of Goku
because he could read his mind that
makes the utility of a form like ultra
instinct all the better as he can move
without thought in that there's actually
a significant amount of great animation
in this episode to know Toshi sheena
most obviously contributes a wonderful
bid half ways through but this section
supplied by Miyako suji was impressive
to the Tschida portion of the fight
however is spectacular but the context
is weird by the time the cut ends goku
has caused more damage to the earth than
hearts has something to think about
hearts then reactivates his gravity
power because he's not completely
brain-dead and that ends the episode you
think at some point during the battle
his glasses would fall off too but they
are right there firmly on his face and
something tells me they will be there
for a long time
episode 14 so hearts turns off the
gravity power because I guess he is
fully brain-dead he powers up more and
they continue fighting piccolo and 17th
successfully tag-team kami Oran and
through a combo of shields blasts of a
conch Oh suppose begin dominating hearts
notices that commie Oran is being
dominated and gives the fighters
seemingly a bunch of new power I don't
exactly know how or why 17 and piccolo
can defeat this character even before
all this considering when separated
common and Oran were single-handedly
dishing out beatings to hit and Vegeta
but whatever not like continuity is a
big deal and storytelling anyways with
this powerup we get this episode's a new
toy I mean fighter for the gang to
battle with it looks pretty much like
Haroon Agarn and got this power from the
universe seed or something that hearts
is in possession of now the gang all try
battling this new souped-up version of
cameo and but to no avail
Goku tries his best but two fails before
attaining for the third time ultra
instant to close out the episode episode
15 I'd like to point out that hit
enduring despite being extremely
valuable in this fight have not been
seen in ages for apparently no reason at
all to know why they can't just take the
bus to Goku continues to fight the giant
beasts and proceeds to stomp on him for
about six minutes straight eventually
attending the silver-haired forum in
that time he defeats cameo and while
using all of his energy after this
battle Hart's remarks that the universe
seed has been condensed into this
perfect form
whatever that means it's no time for his
wish to come true according to
masu who seems to be scheming something
also boy the way what happened to
collecting the dragonballs for the last
14 episodes oh it can't be the only one
who's noticed this episode 16
so while Hart's is busy playing with the
universe seed and his cubes a massive
confronts everyone revealing that hearts
was the destroy Zeno and that without
Zeno in the way his plan to eradicate
all mortals will have no obstacles this
is of course ignoring how few samasta
even exists in this timeline or in the
first place considering with what
happened to him in the Goku black arc
and it was in a completely different
timeline I mean it just makes no sense
but Sabah's who starts styling at
everyone and then jiren literally drops
from the heavens to save the day with
hit they start to fight but that's when
hearts decides to leave his cube and to
do his best impression of omega shenron
this this is the worst design for a main
villain i have ever seen and after
cubans imasu into oblivion i guess it's
time to move on episode 17 hearts could
not look more ridiculous like holy hell
like good job I'm actually impressed he
fires these green balls all around
everyone and with a signal snap of his
finger
they begin attacking everyone it's
actually quite boring but eventually
everyone falls to the floor before
restarting the exchange goku hit and
jeering all try attacking but to no
success and that's what hearts uses his
gravity finale and yes that's actually
the name of the move and pretty much
drops a big old cube on everybody this
man loves his cubes the explosion is
shown to be massive and impressive and
all the rest of it but despite this
everyone gets up afterwards with a few
scratches ready to keep fighting
what is stamina in this show this is
when goku and vegeta
for the second or third time i can't
remember talk about fusing goku decides
that fusion is what they need to do and
Vegeta refuses despite maybe a few hours
ago doing just that
after more moaning from Vegeta they
perform the dance perfectly the first
time and we get Gogeta in the show whoo
episode 18 heart sends the rest of the
fighters to the floor and invites Gogeta
to battle who is powered up to blue they
fight for a bit hearts plays with more
cubes all to no success against Gogeta
they fight some more they talk Hart says
that he's stronger than Zeno and Gogeta
says that he's stronger than Hart's it's
a pretty boring episode if I'm being
perfectly honest Hart's closes this
without by making a super big blast and
hurls it towards Gogeta
episode 19 alright so this episode is
pegged as being the end of the you
conflict dark so let's see how it fares
Gugino fires economy how to stop the
blast but he's struggling hearts calls
himself the very universe itself weird
flex but okay but then the allies of
Kochi to step in to lend a hand together
they make a spiral e-beam and we all
know that means the beam is stronger in
Dragon Ball super but the destruction
blast the heart sent their way gets
broken up and then Gojira moves in to
finish Hearts which he does hats goes on
to deliver a speech about liberating the
universe from Zeno and all that nonsense
that he could have said a number of
times during this series but never did
what an anticlimactic ending I'm not
sure what I expected apparently Zeno has
been playing hide-and-seek with beerus
and champa this entire time okay the two
sayings on fuse and everyone involved
goes back to their respective universes
Fuu closes out the episode all ominous
like he's some sort of puppet master
which he is apparently I just don't like
it or believe it he comes off as
annoying and not at all sinister episode
20 this episode is a really weird one
and it's sort of a standalone one too
it's considered a special but trust me
there's nothing special about it
this is heroes after all and it's the
most fanfiction thing I've ever seen in
my life all the while sporting a Super
Saiyan God
trunks designed that might very well be
the most disgusting thing I've ever seen
in Dragonball and I've seen piyo prolly
essentially the time patrol is fighting
this evil force I didn't bother to
remember his name trunks get some dumb
looking sword he cuts the bad guy at
half the episode reaches its end in like
three minutes and the rest is just
wrapping up on the details it's honestly
like we showed up at the theater in time
to catch the last seven minutes of a
would hour-long movie I actually have
whiplash after watching this dreadfully
bad idea for an episode and also the
closing seconds provide a small origin
for food that greedy does nothing for me
and I think I'm gonna leave it there for
now there are two episodes more but they
are only the beginning of the next arc
in the series but yeah that's super
Dragon Ball heroes what a weird right I
don't know what I was expecting when I
sat down to review this show for the
first time but it certainly wasn't this
for both good and bad reasons let's talk
about the good first because there are
some good points to this little
advertisement the combat in parts was
decent and some
time's gripping the animation supplied
over the course of the series has been
hit-or-miss but when it hits boy doesn't
hand it out of the park
additionally as I mentioned in the
review the show made a decent effort in
linking the two arcs together making it
feel like one big story instead of two
segmented ones and finally the character
of Hearts had some good upsides - he's
quite memorable to me purely down to how
his offence was animated with the cubes
it's very I don't know of Janique but
aside from that I really really didn't
like his or really anyone's design of
the show everything just feels like
professionals took direction from me
when I was like four years old also and
perhaps the show's biggest flaw is that
it feels like random characters show up
out of nowhere to just be a toy
advertisement nothing demonstrates this
more than metal cooler who literally
shows up and leaves in the same episode
never to be seen again but this can be
said about the entire series one episode
there's altra instinct and other there's
Vegeta I know they're those Gogeta hit
durin it goes on and on like that and
it's honestly exhausting as it's really
obvious that it takes the front seat
over the story and the story isn't even
good but it's made worse by having to
play second fiddle to toy and game
advertisements but then again that's
exactly what super Dragon Ball Heroes is
and that's a big advertisement I don't
think it's fair to knock it for being
exactly what it says on the tin so I
guess it does a good job at that but as
I said at the beginning of this video I
have a big announcement I've spent
hundreds of hours over the last year
reviewing large large chunks of Dragon
Balls story and films and while I've
really enjoyed it I think I need a new
challenge everyone's seen Dragon Ball Z
and I do intend on reviewing the
original Dragon Ball at some point in
the future but both of these are too
easy for what I want right now
I want something intimidating and that's
when I had an idea for the most imposing
challenge to ever rise up against almost
1000 chapters and almost as many
episodes long it's been the single most
popular manga for the last 20 years that
is one of the longest-running manga
series in history people have been
telling me that this is one of the best
Shonen anime
there and I've been putting it off for
years and the best part is I know
literally nothing about this show
I've not seen or read a single part of
it and so starting next week we'll be
setting sail as I review for the first
time ever the most popular manga on
earth next week I'm gonna start my
journey to conquer one piece
[Music]